hello everyone and welcome to the best
game of day one of the Magnus
Invitational or rather the one I am
myself enjoyed most so I hope you guys
will enjoy that one as well it's a
really crazy game and Alireza lost the
game - so this is game 3 and he needs a
win to get back into the match so let's
see how how he will do it or maybe not
but ding with the white pieces opens
with Knight to f3 and I didn't mention
in the previous video but yes since all
of you are congratulating me the channel
has reached reached 600,000 subscribers
so there you have it I think you all
really really means the world to me
and regarding it we will we have some
sort of a celebration stream or
something since I can't have any guests
over at the moment due to the corona
situation I decided to skip this one and
probably do maybe like a 750,000
subscribers Indian we're gonna really
commemorate the milestone invite some
guests have a nice a nice party stream
and whatever we usually do but when I
finish up the Magna sensational we could
throw in a nice inhale tall game if you
guys would enjoy that but yeah getting
back to the game and Knight f3 and d5
all it is up goes for my favorite reply
against the rating so let's see how he
deals with it we have g3 and now Knight
to d7 obviously better than preparing e5
with Knight to c6
so he goes nice to d7 preparing d5 and
now some players actually allow black to
play e5 but as I understand it this is
just wrong so Dean prevents it of course
d4 we have nice to be six and now Bishop
to g2 otherwise that goes Bishop to f5
and now I just castles biding with 86
now that the bishop is out of its cage
and Knight B to d2 and c6 now are
closing up the cage completely and here
there is one game where nice to h4 was
played going after the bishop right away
but here being placed c4 and it is as of
move seven already that we have a
completely new game which is not a bad
deal if you considered a and they went
into the dirty opening so D captures and
c4
now just efore grabbing more space in
the center bishop to g6 and the Queen to
d2 now putting pressure on the c4 pawn
however okay there's a defense that
would attack the knight of six so now if
you go after this point you you are
going to lose this pawn and also just a
nice developing move so rook the d1 and
now Bishop to b4 you have to develop the
bishop to to a square a d6 doesn't
really make sense since E 5 wins the
piece Bishop d7 might be a bit slow so
he decides for Bishop to b4 and okay
Knight to e5 biding now offering the d4
pawn and grabbing the d4 pawn would be
very unfortunate for blacks since you
run into a lot of nasty discoveries
after Knight DD captors on c4 opening up
a discovery here the Knights now defend
each other so once the Queen moves you
get a nice the d6 check and so on now
you can just gobble up whatever you want
you can capture the bishop you can
capture on b7 and black no longer has
castling privileges so after Knight to
e5 we have c3 bye Felicia attacking the
knight B captures Bishop captures and
rook to be one and only now does he cast
off the safety
we have Knight to b3 biding and for the
moment Fallujah is up a pond but dink
has a lot of pieces developed so he's
not not really worried about it and he
has a very strong a very strong central
control we have Queen to e7 and now
Bishop to g5 just not allowing this
knife to move and now Queen the a3 it is
a very active square for the Queen
unless it's a too active square for the
Queen
so dingos for rook to d3 puts pressure
on the bishop and it doesn't really help
you if you move the bishop for example
if Bishop b4 nice the c5 really brings a
lot of problems over for black because
your queen is under attack
other than Queen a5 you don't have any
squares now Knight captures on b7 again
attacks the Queen and here you can just
well trade this the white wins back his
pawn and now regains a much better
position this is now week this will be
week you can just go rook c3 pile up on
the pawn here the bishop and the
beautiful diagonal it's just a much
better position
white so after rook to d3 ali reza
defends it with Knight to a4 and now
dink pushes h4 although there was a
there was just an instant tactic with
Knight captures H captures in Queen c2
threatening to win the bishop well two
pieces for the rook and again if if the
bishop moves now there should be one
just just wins
so black wouldn't really have any other
options other than allow white to win
the two pieces for the rook but Dean
says there's no rush he pushes h4 first
and now ali reza pushes c5 and here
really a complicated position anything
anything can be played here but there is
one move and one combination which which
is above all and it is the one that
being played so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
for doing here well while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
as it is not an easy tactic to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's possible to go from Knight
to c4 first and there is even a line
with Knight characters on c5 but the
most straightforward one and the one I
hope you find found is a bishop captures
on f6 you grab the night here and after
G captures now just Knight to c4 and now
the Queen has nowhere to go
well okay Queen has before but now also
the move you have to see Knight B to d2
opening up a discovery and now the Queen
has no more squares so Ali raises Queen
is trapped but he doesn't give up of
course he continues the game with Bishop
captures and e2 he gives up the Queen
rook captures and Bishop captures rook
so a knight and the rook for a queen not
a bad deal and the Dean now continues
pushing with h5 hence the inclusion of H
for the bishop is now trapped but now
ELISA finds the very interesting b5 and
he played it pretty much instantly which
poses a lot of problems for example if
you move the knight you allow c4 and
then the past pawn just starts marching
forward so here didn't decide that okay
he doesn't my trading pieces and he's
going to open up the black Kings
position so
each captures ng6 we have B captors and
C 4 and now G captures on h7 with check
Alireza goes King h8 of course not
capturing at allowing Queen h5 with
check and now rook to f3 and getting the
rock out of harm's way and now c3 Ali
Reza now has a passed pawn and it is a
very strong passed pawn and now Dean
decides to go for a 3 it seems like a
reasonable tactic however a Larissa
finds a beautiful way to refute it a 3
and of course if you capture them the
Queen here will just win either either
of the pieces so all there is a place C
capture son d4 instead he gives up yet
more material if they have two connected
passed pawns in the center of the board
so a capture son before and now rook ate
the c8 and now just putting a room
behind the passed pawn we want you to
put this rogue behind the other passed
pawn it those two points will be
extremely fast so Queen to c2 blocking
and now Knight the b2 guarding the d3
square preparing pawn to d3 and now
brush up the f1 only good move for ding
you have to cover the d3 square rook F
to d8
again preparing to push and now you
block it with the bishop and here yes
ding has a queen but his queen is
currently stuck along with the bishop
preventing those passports from marching
forward so e 5 by ali reza and now comes
g4 biding he once the make some room for
the rook and also at some point he wants
to play g5 to open up the position we
have King captures on h7 now there's no
reason in allowing ding to have a passed
pawn on h7 any longer and now King to F
1 we have Knight captures on b3 rook
captures on d3 rope characters on d3 and
now rook the c4 going after the beep on
as well and that would create another
passed pawn for Alireza and here ding
plate Queen to C 1 but there's also a
very interesting idea that is g5 here
I'm not going to ask you to find it as
it's not not all that clear but
basically it would it what it asks you
to do is free this diagonal for the
Queen so next whatever play is played
you're just gonna play Queen e2 bring
the Queen over to h5 rook to h3
and a checkmate the black King and if
you end if black of course does not
react to it if something like rook to c6
to defend the pawn then rock h3 check
King g6 and now Queen d1 with with the
same idea or Queen e2 it doesn't really
matter
we'll be winning for white but dink went
for Queen to see one instead probably
preparing g5 but now King to g7 and now
the when the King leaves the h-file the
King is a much safer with g5 biding but
now f5 by ali reza and here he captures
an f5 of course is possible but ding
decides to go for g6 instead and here or
it's just extremely complicated and with
both players being very long time it's
impossible to calculate everything f
captures an e4 was played and now dean
for some reason doesn't doesn't move the
rook if you move the rook yes these past
bonds look scary but at least you you
save your rook and it is the way to go
however however bleak I mean you have to
play it then III preventing the Q Queen
from entering the game and then again
anything can happen those past ones are
really scary
however Dean played G captures on f7
with the idea that he can deliver check
and grab this rook but all it is it just
happily captures on d3 and now those
pawns are incredibly scary
so Queen g5 check King captures on f7
but now the problem is if Dean captures
rook then D 2 is coming king e 2 C 2 is
coming and Alireza will either bring
another Queen enter game or ding will
have to somehow somehow achieve a draw
or just Queen d5 check and maybe you try
to pick up the rook but still it's it
will not be possible for example if
Queen d5 check you can move the King
King f8 and now of course you cannot
capture the rug because this comes with
check so you would have to just continue
checking the King and hope you can get a
draw by Perpetual checks so after King
captures on f7
ding continue with Queen f5 check King
that East 7 and Queen captures on e5
with check King the f7 and here we just
have Queen a5 checking g7 25 check and
King to f7 and it was in this position
that
the players agreed to a draw or it is a
draw threefold repetition because if
future continues with some like King d7
then you can actually go for this check
and after King g7 you can actually
capture this d2 and now the problem is
king he to d3 wit check doesn't really
work you you will not have any way to
continue king d1 now C to check you can
just pick up the pawn here and the king
and queen protect against all the pawns
so Allah dies I saw that there's no way
to do this King to f7 was played and
like I said the game ended in a draw but
incredibly crazy tactical game
dink-dink didn't want to spend too much
time to work out all of the intricacies
of the position and it it was just
enough to give the the slippery Alireza
a chance to escape this game with a draw
or maybe it was Dean who escaped this
game even though the engine I mean says
that white is completely winning when
you're faced with those so many past
pawns
you know and the clock is ticking it's
it's not easy to find the correct moves
so brilliant game but both of them
adding out playing all areas are
completely in the opening but then
aleeah's are showed show ding that he is
the master of tactics but yeah
second the game went went to dink a
third game ends in a draw and the fourth
game also ended in a draw
so by winning game 2 ding wins the match
against ali reza and he is now leading
at the magnus invitational because he
receives more points for winning the
match right away then Magnus did by
beating he can talk more in the
Armageddon so for the moment ding
leading but we have another set of
players today so of course the Magnus
Invitational continues so I really
enjoyed this game I do hope you agree
that it is the best game of day 1 so
feel free to comment and that as well I
would like to thank Enric James Barbados
Balaji colony upon our pony temper my
knee and shorts and grin for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus invitational until it ends so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent receivers